so I think you said earlier that most of
the screenplays that you've sold have
been through prior working relationships
where you knew the person but when you
did go and pitch because it sounds like
you you have done that when someone said
no what did that no mean to you um it
meant that the project wasn't right for
them at that time you know I I think you
have to be you have to have a lot of
confidence in your writing first of all
to get to that level where you're able
to pitch and they're willing to take a
pitch from you you're probably at a
level where you know you're a pretty
good writer so you can't let that
discourage you I mean there are projects
that we've pitched all over town that I
still love and I still think are great
projects and no one's bought them and so
it's just it wasn't the right time for
that you can kind of obsess over that if
you want but the best thing to do is you
just keep moving on go to your next one
go to your next one you can always come
back and revisit something later and a
lot of times when you do revisit it you
start to see things about it that you
didn't see before like oh I should have
done this differently or knowing what I
know now I would do this because you're
just more informed than you were before
so that's to me you just don't let it
discourage you that's the biggest take
away from that did you always have that
approach to it or was the first time you
know sort of I always had that approach
I I think my attitude was always and I
think I've gotten softer as I've gotten
older but I think when I was younger my
attitude was always like well you know
if they don't like it forget them you
know I'm moving on to the next person
like if they don't get it someone else
will
so but I think that is the right
attitude to have and now I think you
know I think that you can you can
internalize a lot of things on the right
and I think writers tend to we're always
looking for like oh what did I do wrong
what could I do better what you know why
isn't this working for me and I think
that if you just stay true to what you
believe in eventually you're gonna find
that audience that's gonna connect to
that and that producer and maybe it's
just the timing maybe you just haven't
met them yet but again it goes to why
network
is so important expanding that group of
people and networking and finding the
right people that you want to work with
that who creatively aligned with you is
really really important yeah and the
interesting thing is to so many things
changed behind the scenes whatever part
of the industry that you're in and
you'll never know why and you won't know
is it me is it what what was it did I
say the wrong thing whatever it's how
actors is all the time from a director
standpoint when we do auditions and they
you know they come into the room and
they have five minutes to do their read
we know the moment they walk in if it's
a no and Wow
I tell actors all the time like don't
obsess over what you should have said
differently or how you should have
delivered a line it's not even about
that they either we either connected you
to that character or we didn't period
and it's sort of the same with writing
you know you're gonna find people who
you just at one point you're gonna be
the one this is the project someone
loves this project it's what they want
to do and they get it but there's gonna
be lots of people who don't you know
that's why there's lots of stuff on
television that's why there's lots of
movies playing at any given time you
know it's there's not one thing for
everybody so don't take no for an answer
just keep moving like that
you